the economic crisis was becoming social
crisis if action is now not taken to
employment creation of quality
appointment the center of the agenda on
economic policy internationally in the
short term that needs governments to
focus and show a recovery translates
more quickly into employment creation
nor medium-term to make sure the model
of economic growth coming out of this
crisis is more balanced or balance
between labor and capital between rich
and poor and between different regions
of the world when in the past that means
also a focus on the quality of
employment creating decent work and
reducing income gaps and inequality
those are challenges that we're to avoid
and major social crisis down the road
coming out of this economic and
financial risks